[Music]
[Applause]
happy thursday everyone
so did you hear the latest news yep
charles payne accepted my friend request
but also according to npr the january 6
hearings are now extending into july
yeah i guess they're using the same
calendar as two weeks to flatten the
curve
but thank god because the stuff i've
watched so far has been so riveting to
hell with that summer vacation to key
west i know what i'm doing the first
week or two of july yeah
apparently they're going to pursue more
witnesses and say they're going to get
lots of new evidence i guess they're not
happy with the witnesses they originally
cast in the show
what a disaster huh
yeah she made the hindenburg look like a
fender bender
she made pompeii look like knott's berry
farm
that's a weird comparison
apparently they're going to subpoena
trump's white house counsel pat sipoloni
i don't know who already talked to these
clowns and what for
well obviously to salvage the mess they
made with their big star the good news
at least she didn't implicate two
bodybuilding nigerians
[Laughter]
seriously haven't they been through
enough
just wish they'd move out of my
apartment
they take the longest showers
apparently the committee committee
didn't bother to reach out to the secret
service before it aired the crud about
trump lunging at security so i guess
they're doing that now which means new
witnesses become responsible for
repairing other witnesses hearsay
but maybe they'll find out that trump
didn't just lunge at the secret service
he did a double backflip off the trunk
of the car and landed squarely in the
lap of abe lincoln
who knew trump can drive an suv from the
back seat
you won't see that in a bond movie
of course the media will say come on
look it's not a court of law which is
true but how's that helped you
hutchinson's testimony has now been
ruined and by connection so is the
hearing you'd think they'd be experts at
framing trump by now they've had so much
practice
but damn if i wanted to watch a show
trial i'd go to north korea
at least none of the actors there are
fat
it's not by choice though yet it still
goes on and why because the incentives
are in place
first of all you're paying for it like a
night out with kill mead you thought you
foot the bill that's not true
we go dutch yes
leave them out of this
two the media wants it to go on forever
because it feeds their bias and it feels
like they're reporting something when
they're just democrat stenographers
here's one tweet from abc's jonathan
carl it just says
thank you cassidy hutchinson
that's a reporter
i guess he's referring to her testimony
but who knows maybe she shared her
netflix password with him
but that's the media i'm just happy they
left their pom-poms at home
three the dems are in control at least
until november this propaganda machine
can go on till then so don't be
surprised if it does
because like joe on the steps of air
force one there's just no balance
without legit pushback you see that
democrat politics is actually stalinist
politics
show me the donald and i'll show you the
crime
so one wonders what's really worse
that a rally got out of hand for one day
a rally in which people who never broke
the law before broke the law then got
arrested and are serving time which they
should because they broke the law
or an open-ended one-party media
protected tribunal
paid for by you
to save their party's chanters chances
in november while persecuting anyone
they can in this unfettered witch hunt
well the answer is easier than me after
three daiquiris
or two
ah one meanwhile our government ignores
people illegally intimidating supreme
court justices how's that
so is this america where they offer
unsubstantiated allegations that fall
apart like a slow cooked pork shoulder
then use that to compel more testimony
testimony by reluctant participants in
front of grim partisan hacks
we now see how duped everyone is to fall
for the insurrection lie
it was all to create a spectacle to
divert from their failures
so if you bought this bs you got
chainied
and you thought her dad only shot
friends in the face
she contributed to a show trial that
would make joe mccarthy blush
did you see right after testifying the
star witnessed rushed to embrace liz
what's that mean are they old friends
no they're just part of the play they're
hugging like cast members of snl when
the show's over
how would liz cheney even know this
low-level executive branch employee
unless of course they met at rehearsal
so what's this mean for you
that you gotta vote
the only way to stop this is to vote
every
brained democrat out of office
and then
and then let the real hearings begin
because now we have the smoking gun the
laptop the messages the big man
admitting he knew what his corrupt son
was up to roll the voicemail
your chance give me a call no it doesn't
i just want to talk to you i thought the
article at least has been on online it's
going to be printed tomorrow in times is
good
i make you clear
i think you're clear
talk about real first-person evidence of
all sorts of multiple felonies right on
tape which was buried by the press
compare that to this show trial
full of mind reading and hearsay that's
amplified by the press it's crazy
i just hope there are more there are
more phone messages from joe to hunter
hey pal it's dad again uh
[Music]
i was just thinking um you know that the
voicemail i left you the one about the
uh
you're all clear
uh you know to delete that right
yeah you're a smart kid all right
and um just call me a big guy from now
on right no one's gonna know what that
means all right love you bye
you know what
i
i think there's one more right
hey pal it's dad again um hey look um
i was just thinking while we're deleting
things
i was thinking maybe the uh
1400 videos of you with the hookers and
the cocaine
[Laughter]
yeah i think you can get rid of those
i know it's
it's fun to look back
i think it's time we give those the old
scrub-a-dub huh
the old scrub-a-dumb
this is gonna be great
because these people should pay for
wasting our time with these hearings
while ignoring crime inflation border
atrocities it's our turn for justice and
i'm going to be here for it not because
i'm a journalist not because i'm a
republican pretty sure i'm neither it's
because i'm an american a pissed off one
too and you should be as well
let's welcome tonight's
guests
she's so bright we're all wearing
sunscreen for protection fox news
contributor laura trump
unlike baby formula his book is still on
the shelves
boxing friends coast and host of the
great new show what made america great
on fox nation brian killme
he's living in alaska pursuing comedy
next he'll probably pursue snowboarding
in florida
actor writer and comedian jamie lisa
she's got a lot of skeletons in her
closet and most of them are squirrels
fox who's contributor cat tim
brian how you doing there champ good
you've been so nice to me and i'm really
worried yeah yeah i'm saving it all i
guess so saving it all maybe you're just
looking forward to the week yeah i felt
bad yeah i feel bad for you i know
things haven't been going well i didn't
say that no no it's it you know it's
it's the scuttlebutt in the kitchen
really yeah at the fox kitchen people
people know the problems we have a
kitchen yeah we have a well they don't
tell you about it
but you know it's amazing to see lynn
cheney become a hero
to the liberals now the liberals are now
neocons
she said i i look forward to the day and
we can disagree again on issues and i
just think it was so i thought the most
telling thing was actually came from
jake tapper when he said he's talking to
jamie raskin and he just said you know
it would be great if we had some
corroboration like a second sewer so
he's like oh that's not a trial we just
thought it'd be good for you to know
yeah we're starting to say stuff we have
no idea if it's true or not but isn't it
exciting to get together with everybody
in the audience and everything like that
this is impeachment three it's the same
thing it's the same thing except for
there's no cross-examination this is the
key though if they don't sit those
secret service agents down to tell their
side of the story they can't even
pretend that they are trying to get the
other side of the story because these
guys go excuse me i got a huge problem
with that story and it's the fact that
it didn't happen and i'd like to go sit
there and go under oath and tell you
what happened and the networks just
froze in the headlights they have no
idea how to handle it when they come
back in july which i'm concerned is
going to go right into the new season of
ted lasso wow and that's my big worry
when they come back in july i want to
see secret servants guys with earpieces
on there saying not true no one grabbed
the wheel no one assaulted me uh and i
think what else what else did cassidy
say that needs to be i love can i love
the uh
i'm i'm so shocked lara i'm so shocked
he threw his lunch
who hasn't thrown any like
the whole point of lunch is that i have
not you haven't yeah we don't even eat
lunch you get an extra lunch to throw i
haven't
i always order two sandwiches laura one
to eat and one to throw at my assistant
it's
are you watching any of this uh
absolutely not look we all saw this
movie the first time it was called
russia collusion right so we've seen it
we know the goal we know the whole point
of this and yes they're extending it
what a shocker into july
do we think it'll extend i don't know
into november maybe
the midterm elections this whole thing
honestly it's kind of insulting to the
american people because people have real
problems out there
and this is where our elected officials
are putting their time energy our money
as you just pointed out in your intro
greg it is insane but i love all the
memes that came out of the other day
with cassidy hutchinson the ones of my
father-in-law driving the the
presidential limo and taking down secret
service agents it wasn't too long ago
that they were asking could donald trump
hold a glass of water exactly and now
he's taken down secret service agents
you gotta hand it to donald trump he's
really one on this one i gotta say
[Applause]
good to see you jamie you too i'm lying
are you where i felt like i wasn't
um
can i say real quick i saw an article
today that you're crushing in the
ratings i want to take one second and
say congratulations oh why thank you and
um
we are
we you know uh just a side point do you
know that the five has more democratic
viewers than anybody on msnbc and this
show has like more has more affluent
viewers than any show i saw that and if
you're free later i'd like to buy you
three daiquiris
all you need is one apparently just one
another okay i want to make sure
[Laughter]
so that was all a big setup you big jerk
and i fell for it
but honestly this whole thing you said
you said it killed me that it's they
don't want to hear the other side of the
story yeah this whole thing is hearsay
like the whole thing is here like it'd
be like on the way here like a homeless
guy said something to me he was like oh
this guy is falling i can't come in here
and report that to you yeah he wasn't
under oath he was under bridge
and it's getting crazy out there by the
way people should be careful yeah
there's just it's some crazy people i
was in line for a pretzel yes and this
guy i'm just having trouble telling the
difference between uh businessmen and
crazy people because the ear pieces are
getting smaller right so have you ever
i'm i'm buying a pretzel and this guy he
look he's right in my face and he goes
listen man if we don't get those reports
by tomorrow we're all screwed
[Laughter]
and i go what are you talking about he
goes listen i don't want your excuses i
just want a report and i go dude i don't
even know what you're talking about and
he points his ear and i go i can hear
you i just have no idea
what we're talking about and i started
thinking
how drunk was i last night that i
somehow got a job
and now i've missed my first assignment
but enough with the hearsay it's a joke
i'm not watching one second of this yeah
you know it's funny what i don't even
know what hearsay means cat
hear it say i think you do oh do i
they should call it the january
hear saying yes
not hearing right but here's saying i it
hit me you know he's trying out material
on your show are you a little insulted i
mean he's going to take what works he's
going to go on stage he has been on
every line he's been on every day this
week it's okay it's okay yeah to do that
you can't do it all right it's all right
but he can do it okay you can't what
about you cat and your different glasses
yeah yeah i am wearing different glasses
yes
which you've mentioned to me three times
that you don't like yes
which is so disappointing because when i
get dressed every day all i'm thinking
is i hope greg likes this
uh any okay you want me to talk about
the the hearing yes all right sure i can
do that okay uh i i just i don't think
it's going to be effective for what they
want it to be effective for
and you know the bachelorette is you
know starting in july and it's the first
time with two bachelorettes it's two
yeah so it's like will their friendship
withstand them competing over men
yeah they were eliminated the previous
season
and so i'm definitely tuning in and also
twins
no they're not twins no
see i would watch if they were like
siamese twins
and then and we actually see this cat
siamese twins and one
like gets what do they do if one gets
rejected i think you should talk to fox
nation that's a great idea yes yes um
but also i think anyone who's watching
it already agrees with the what the
point of it is and i don't think anybody
who's a like a big trump supporter is
watching it right and even if they like
you know they're not sitting there like
all right that's it
i'm taking off the hat yeah right
i don't think it does make any
difference no it's not it's oh it's this
is a this is
masturbatory theater for people with
trump derangement syndrome they need to
watch us to tell them that everything
and they can't let go that's the thing
which is probably a poor analogy but
anyway
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else